it's a good segue from Skyrim because
you did a really great feature video on
when remasters changed too much yeah of
the original game which is an
interesting take on because we're always
talking about are they just cash cows
are they just developers publishers
cashing in on existing stuff that they
can just you know port almost but I
don't I want to pick your brain a little
more discreet video you can go watch on
gamespot com or YouTube but what at what
point i guess like you kind of came to
the conclusion that sometimes remasters
can kind of sacrifice what made the
original game great and also not really
preserve it as well i know you brought
up like doom 3 can you talk about that
specific example dhoom3 is definitely
one that likes me because in the
original doom 3 is kind of infamous for
its flashlight you can't use it and the
gun at the same time and that bothered a
lot of people and I mean if you're a fan
of the original dooms that it's very
understandable dhoom3 is a completely
different game than those original dooms
region current doom now but it kind of
makes that game unique it gives a game
its own identity so uh you know people
would have liked there's the duct tape
mod which oh we're gonna like just
attach the flashlight to the gun through
mods and that's fine if you want to mod
a game that's your own business but then
when they did that remaster bfg edition
in 2012 so that was like eight years
later they just were like hey that that
mod is just official this is how the
game is and they'd like not even a menu
option and that's I think that's the
part that actually bugged me about it
was that you couldn't choose whether you
wanted to play in the old style or the
new styles just here's the new style
this is how the game it was almost like
them saying like no this is how we
always meant the game to be like it just
they realize their mistake yeah like
backpedaling on it but the problem is is
everything about the game is designed
around that original flashlight like the
way the monster closets and the scares
and the lighting it's all designed
around not being able to use the gun in
the flash at the same time so when you
suddenly can just have the flashlight
out whenever you want it's like none of
the tensions there anymore yeah I played
a lot of doom 3 myself and I remember
liking the flashlight a lot because even
when I had the flashlight on could see
around there's always
back in my mind knowing that at any
moment I have to swap really quickly to
a gun and then try to shoot someone in
the dark and that was like great lent
itself well to the horrors that game I
think totally and I never played the
duct tape mod and I didn't play bfg in
2012 i think you said it released I
don't know but that was interesting to
look at how they it's weird it's like
striking a balance with these remasters
between preserving what made the
original game the original game what
lent its character but also kind of
updating it for modern pallets and you
also brought up the Bioshock remastered
collection bioshock 1 specifically if
i'm not mistaken right yeah that one's
more the more noticeable 12 also has
some changes as well but I like to but
no one no one else cares about to I like
watch active me to figure out a way to
talk about more about that one's really
minor honestly like you look at a lot of
it and it's like the I think the
gameplay is still there like that game
plays the same although it's also really
buggy that um that port in like somehow
worse in like I was playing it recently
and they like patched it and before I
actually didn't have that many problems
with the remaster I was like okay cool
like you know I've heard people have had
problems I was fine they did a patch I
then tried to play it again and all the
audio was broken it's like the human
right worse but that one they just do
like weird texture changes where it's
like oh hey there's this carpet that was
like in this floor and now it's just not
there and only like it doesn't change
the game like Bioshock still Bioshock
but a certain point you just kind of
looking at your like so were they just
like looking at this room and thinking
well we got to change something about it
to make it worth the 60 bucks or
whatever it is you're paying for this so
I guess we'll change the carpet and you
know like if that texture is a little
different now yeah present evil 4 is
also really good one the pc version of
resin evil 4 which you know it's a good
version of that game but the textures
you look at them in like they're
actually very different like the oh the
wood texture looks like completely
different and a lot of fans they're
actually doing a mod to restore the
original textures and higher res which
is really weird that we now have like
mods that are like no no no this is the
true HD master and they doom 3 actually
the same thing a lot of modders like did
a modded version of original doom 3 to
make it like a better version than the
bfg edition that actually
the flashlight and all that stuff super
weird so this isn't us this is the
different than what you just described
represents the difference between a
publisher and someone who you know cares
about a game like as a customer as
someone who is experiencing this because
publishers do not act based on altruism
you know what I mean yeah there to make
money so if they focus-test a thing and
it's like oh yeah people prefer this now
that's the way they're going to do it
and like totally grounds for us to feel
like that sucks but it's never it's
never going to be it's never going to be
a scenario where the publisher really
cares enough about preserving the game
yeah so much is being able to package it
in an attractive way and you got to
imagine as well like you know eight
years ten years after the fact these
companies that have totally different
teams working on the game there's no one
there to like who even has the power to
stand up and say I believe in this and
you all have to listen to me sure you
know like in that's it really sucks it
really really does suck leads me to what
I think is universally accepted as a
huge blunder you mentioned the video and
then you could speak to this as well
final fantasy soap bubble do you ever
play it beat for like a minute because
then you saw it and then couldn't stand
it's grotesque yeah it's awful even if
someone who never played the original I
mean I've seen our work and it's
gorgeous it's still as looking at that
right now but once they went to mobile
USM did were those time left is yours
did you find a video or someone did this
I did that it's really cool looking yeah
he change the back on itself he said it
looks like it's just traced over now and
then the character models become really
ugly I I don't like it I don't have I've
never played Final Fantasy 6 it just
seems pretty egregious I don't know like
how much of his results of having to
have on mobile devices can you have like
the original pixel art on borders
totally yeah no I mean this is this
isn't and what's worse is like this
isn't even bad because they altered what
was original it's bad because they
altered it with something that just
looks objectively worse yeah that's just
ugly no one can look at this unless they
need glasses and they're not wearing
them and say oh yeah this passes the
test yeah like this looks like [ __ ] yeah
it would be one thing if they completely
redid it like you know new art style
like new interpretation but I had like a
cohesive vision like this is because the
background looks like kind of the old
art but then like smudgy and then like
there's new characters and like there's
just no consistency to any of it
it's really bad and it totally
illustrates the point I was just making
cuz file of a c6 is one of the most
beloved console games of all time and
the company who owns it doesn't even
freaking realize it and understand what
they have I guess a fan could have
ported the game to mobile better than
them yeah the hell and the part that
really I think just like drives to stake
in for me is that that's the version on
steam like if you want to get it on
Steam it's the mobile port hope that
imported to steam and that is Square
Enix saying this is what we consider to
be like the definitive version going
forward for Final Fantasy 6 which sucks
for people that enjoy games in general
and good looking things i but especially
for me I've never played Final Fantasy 6
and if it were just if it were preserved
as it looked on mobile devices or if it
they had ported the original person over
to mobile devices I would play it on my
phone probably the best way for you to
play it now without resorting to
emulators is to play the game boy
advance port yeah cuz even the
PlayStation port sucks it's got horrible
loading times what about the virtual
console version was it on virtual closes
on Virtual Console agency that I think
you could do that that is the original
version that's something I like about
Nintendo is I also talked about how
they've been doing like remasters of
Zelda games and they make changes you
know like the fast sale and Iron Boots
are now an item instead of an equip
totally which is like makes that whole
puzzle like so less tedious but even if
you don't like some of those changes
they have all of those original versions
on the Virtual Console so you can still
no load up like the n64 version of
Ocarina or you know like the gamecube
version of winwaker is still accessible
like e nintendo at least gives you the
ability to go play those original
versions which I really appreciate and
you also brought up the halo master
chief collection which despite the like
numerous bugs at the beginning with
multiplayer and what not even some fries
of the game which I believe have all
been fixed now at least I hope I really
liked that collection because you just
for the first game the Masters the halo
anniversary edition of combat Evolved
you just press the back button it shows
you the original if I understand they're
running the code a lot like behind the
new one so you just switch between them
or something which is crazy yeah that as
much as I don't care about halo I'm
super impressed by the effort they put
into making that possible from my
limited knowledge that sounds like a lot
of work and I know like that kind of
that sounds like they actually took the
time to you know
serve it obviously exists the original
game once you go back in it's the sound
effects to like it goes back to the
original assault rifle sound effects
used to be this throaty kind of growl in
the first game then it become came this
like ratatat kind of thing but if you
switch back I don't know it's it it's
crazy it also makes you realize how much
better it looks because you could just
swap between them yeah that was an
awesome like remaster collection yeah
and the Lucas arts and Double Fine's
been doing a great job with the old
adventure yeah point click adventure
game so like a monkey island let's do
switch between the old arts down the new
art style sure and then they also like
added voice acting and then they'll even
do cool mixes were like hey do you want
to play with the old art style but you
also want to play with the voice acting
you can do stuff like that you can play
with the tank controls if you want for
grim fandango or you can play with like
new controls like i like that they give
you the option to play these like in a
more modern way that like most players
will probably just play Grim Fandango
with like modern control saying they
won't even share those tank controls and
they probably wouldn't like them but
having that option for those players who
played those original games i think is
really important sure it's kind of like
more pertinent now we have this year we
had gears war Ultimate Edition we have
the Uncharted collection sorry that was
last year there's still recent we had
you know Skyrim now and then we have a
system shocks on the one you mentioned
which again the original games controls
were pretty awful and I remember I did
this like longer feature I'm looking
glass studios who main system shock and
I remember like going back for research
to play system shock I played it two
years ago for the first time with the
original controls oh my god I'm glad I'm
hoping they updated for the sake of like
anybody who plays that game so they're
very much we did on Good Old Games they
put out an enhanced version which like
updates the graphics a little bit and
added like actual mouse controls sure
because i think that game actually it
kind of holds up still like it's like
it's a good well-designed game those
original controls even back then we're
like garbage yeah stuff like that's good
to have definitely if you're a fan of
like Bioshock or dishonored that kind of
vein of like patient first person
shooters kind of narrative driven you
definitely maybe go back to System Shock
you have time I would recommend it but
yeah in general I don't know we're just
talked about skyrim and how the sixty
dollar price point kind of seems like
maybe being too cynical i don't think we
are though maybe that kind of seems
unjustified but then you have things
like the master chief collection you
have things like system
shop which preserve the original
controls you have lucasarts and double
find doing there you know like new voice
acting and also just updating their
graphics you can swap between them just
like massive collection seems like some
people are doing it right preserving the
original game some people are just kind
of trying to cash in which is
unfortunate give a shout out to frank's
volume like Micah who worked on the Mega
Man legacy collection because they not
only write one yeah they not only ported
those games in a way that it's not even
it I think it's running the games and
they compile dynamically to run on the
new processor either way it's like some
of the most faithful porting I've ever
seen and they include a ton of
historical data scanning manual scanning
box are doing all this stuff that was
never available before I'm putting that
in there so you know if a remaster is
supposed to celebrate a game like [ __ ]
Megaman Legacy Collection did the best
job of that of any game I've seen
awesome I've never played it I don't
think but the phone never heard Megaman
if Megaman know I've never know weird
what is it like um your blue dude I
think you have a dog I've never played
it live yeah but those mighty number 9
oh [ __ ] you're right just kidding
alright so jean-luc thanks so much for
coming on and like I said everybody
watching and listening on iTunes what
where you might be listening to us go
check out John this video it's uh when
do remasters change too much yep it's on
gamespot's on youtube go check out it's
a very good watch but anyway if you're
joining us today thanks so much i'm not
gonna sign off on the whole show yet i
just realized we still gotta sign off on
Skyrim I'm getting tired Pete wake up
Mike all right anyway so what do you
think of remasters specifically let us
know if what your most favorite one was
recently and whether you think that a
developer should keep cash in on these
things Ching
you